but first we want to bring you
highlights from the most anticipated
debate of the midterm calendar of course
I'm talking about mehmed Oz versus John
fetterman in Pennsylvania now
let me just say this
if this had been a boxing match the
referee would have called this in the
first 60 seconds and now in case you
need reminding it wasn't your
run-of-the-mill debate because due to
his stroke fetterman required special
dispensations
you may notice these large monitors that
are behind us this is part of our closed
captioning system it was requested by
John fetterman to help him process the
questions that we are asking him tonight
but right off the bat it was pretty
clear that fetterman would need a lot
more than that big screen what qualifies
you to be a U.S senator you have 60
Seconds
hi good night everybody
good night well scary thought that might
have been actually the best moment of
the entire debate for fetterman
one of the most remarkable exchanges was
about fetterman's views on fracking
I absolutely support fracking I believe
that we need independence with energy
and I believe I've walked that line my
entire career you have made two
conflicting statements regarding
fracking in a 2018 interview you said
quote I don't support fracking at all I
never have but earlier this month you
told an interviewer quote I support
fracking I support the energy
Independence that we should have here in
the United States I've always supported
fracking and I always believe that
independence with our energy is is
critical or we can't be held you know
you know Ransom to somebody like Russia
but there is that 2018 interview that
you said quote I don't support fracking
at all so how do you square the two
oh I I I do support fracking and
I don't I don't
I support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
wow now when he wasn't lying there were
these bizarre moments
the abortion decision should be left up
the states and specifically when John
ferryman with Doug mostriano
I've talked to families you want to cut
Social Security Mr fetterman it's his
term for his closing
he kept like screaming out random
thoughts that was during Oz's closing
statement
so look Whoever thought it was a good
idea to put fetterman out there not only
tonight but to run for the U.S Senate
that was cruel and it was a total fraud
will you pledge tonight to release those
records in the interest of transparency
you had 60 seconds
to me for transparency is about showing
up I'm here today to have a debate I
have run a campaign and I've been very
transparent didn't hear you say you
would release your full medical records
why not you have 30 seconds
now uh yeah again my Dr L believes that
I'm fit to be serving and that's what I
believe is where I'm standing
now for all the talk of what ableism in
the last few weeks as it relates to
fetterman tonight was kind of a clear
example of it
Dr Oz you know loves free free money
when it's a half a million dollar tax
break on one of his you know homes down
in a ranch in Florida and whether it was
a fifty dollar tax break you know about
his farm in Montgomery County so it's
about supporting and helping you know
young earners excuse me young
young uh
young you know students to to give them
a break I believe that
that supporting uh
remember all those reporters by the way
a couple of weeks ago all rushing to say
that they talked to fetterman and that
he seemed totally fine
well tonight I got to tell you that was
all a lie
so my question is what else are those
reporters covering up
the Democrats in the media they should
have been honest with themselves and the
voters from the very beginning
but they would rather lie and they would
rather cover up they would rather hide
the ball and then give the voters the
actual facts necessary to help make good
decisions about who should be in charge
and what policies we should adopt
look the only way to stop this the only
way to get the media and the Democrats
to tell us the truth
is to punish them for their lies what
you saw over the last several months
with fetterman filled with lies they
have to learn that when they lie to the
voters they will suffer politically now
until that happens the lies will
continue
joining me now is Molly Hemingway
editor-in-chief of the Federalist and
Fox News contributor Molly I really do
think that's the most important point to
come out of tonight
they jumped on that poor NBC reporter
what a couple weeks ago Dasha Burns for
supposedly skewing what fetterman's
condition really was or or being an able
ableist about his you know stroke
doesn't this just pull the curtain back
on the U.S media once again
yes when Dasha Burns reported that she
wasn't sure fetterman was fully able to
communicate with her without this
assistance she was Trashed by other
people in the media who mocked her and
said that he was totally fine those
people look horrible right now they
clearly were lying or they clearly did
not know enough to to accurately convey
the situation but it does remind you
that the media did this exact same
operation with Joe Biden in the 2020
campaign he also was suffering and not
able to endure the rigors of a campaign
they lied about it they protected him
they even kept debates until the very
last part of the campaign cycle and so I
think you're right they'll keep doing it
they keep doing it with all sorts of
candidates I mean this is not the first
debate we've had where we have seen the
Republican candidate do a very good job
after after the media presented the race
in a different manner before this before
this debate began fetterman was really
losing ground MO mostly on the basis of
his policies and his soft on crime
approach he already was going to have a
hard time and had been losing momentum
after this it's just it's an
embarrassment right well Molly you're
right because they're lying about
Biden's condition
they lied about inflation for a year and
now you know we see they lied about
fettermen and and by the way fetterman's
answer to the question on immigration
this is a doozy watch
I don't ever recall in the Statue of
Liberty did they say you know you know
take our tired huddle masses and put
them on a bus and use cheap political
stunts about them I believe we have to
develop a comprehensive and bicartisan
solution to to address our issue here
for immigration here in our nation
Molly of course it's also bad policies
uh that he's advocating for which is
basically just immigration amnesty which
would be open the floodgates even more
yeah we're seeing a lot of these clips
that are so painful to watch of
fetterman but they were all you know
this also was we saw what Mehmet Oz did
in his debate where he was putting forth
some pretty reasonable balanced
viewpoints he came off looking very
respectable and so if you are an
undecided voter going into this debate I
think you're going to look at the
difficulties that fetterman had and the
particular policies he seemed to be
advocating versus what mehmed Oz was
saying and you know on all sorts of
issues whether it's crime or the Border
or inflation or foreign policy there are
a lot of issues that are going into
people's decision on how they're going
to vote and I can't think that
fetterman's camp is feeling very good
about how it went no I felt sorry for
the poor spokesman tonight so he came
out and he basically said given the fact
that he was in the hospital a few months
ago he really took it to the F to
the worst job in the world I do not feel
bad for the people around fetterman I do
feel very bad for fetterman but I am
actually appalled at the people around
fetterman that they did not protect them
I love him more he has family members
um if this had happened to me I would
pray that the people around me would
love me enough to not put me through
this this was this is very bad for them
for the Democrat Party and it's an
embarrassment to the people of
Pennsylvania they deserve far better
than this
yeah Molly great Point thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else